let's bring in newt gingrich fox news
contributor and former house speaker
good morning to you mr gingrich
good morning good morning what's your
reaction when you hear
those words that griff is talking about
and those images well look i think
you're getting exactly what the policy
suggests you'll get
uh president biden has sent a clear
signal
to the world that the united states is
open for illegal immigration
gallup once estimated that to at least
65 million people
who would like to come to the united
states
the numbers is going to keep going up
the system will become unsustainable
by some time probably this summer we'll
be back where we were under president
obama
we'll have tens of thousands of children
wandering around
he'll have the cartels getting paid for
that there are at least two cartels
that have basically given up drugs for
people because they make more money
moving people into the us than they make
moving drugs into the us
so i think this is this is a track
if you want to make sure that the
american system breaks down
and that we are ultimately faced with so
many people you can't possibly manage it
uh this is a terrific strategy but it is
we shouldn't be surprised
we are getting exactly what this kind of
policy delivers yeah you talk about what
the mexican uh
the mexican cartels are getting we even
have rates maybe there's a rate card out
there
u.s border patrol says that if you bring
one person across it's three thousand
two hundred and fifty dollars
african travelers twenty thousand
dollars asians will pay more
the evaluation set out concerns that
there'll be significant influx of
migrants
they expect caribbean asians and middle
easterns to be there
the spring and the summer but it's not
just about republicans and democrats joe
biden and president obama
how about mexican president andres
emmanuel lopez obrador
who said this to reuters they see him
meaning biden as the migrant president
and so many feel that going to reach the
united states
mexico says this is a crisis they want
it addressed
how long could he walk away from this
and and pretend
it's not a five alarm fire
well when you're when you're dealing
with a president who forgets the name of
his secretary of defense
and forgets the name of the pentagon
pika probably
you know i don't know if he walks away
he could probably sit away
forever why would any of this affect him
he'll say oh gee i guess that's probably
a problem and i think we really
underestimate
the degree to which he's detached from
reality and the degree to which
people will later on look back and say
gosh there were terrible consequences
why didn't we know better well we did
know better but we adopted a policy
deliberately
that sends a signal you know everywhere
in the world
whether they're watching fox and friends
or they're just talking to themselves
people gossip and they learn and
everywhere in the world right now the
signal's out
that the u.s has a welcome mat that
president biden would love for you to
come stay
and the economic opportunities in
america despite everything
are still so much better than in most of
the world you can't you can't blame
a father or a mother who wants their
child to grow up here
uh rather than in poverty but you can
blame the american government
for not being honest about the cost of
this this is going to be
extraordinarily expensive it's going to
shake i think the fabric of american
society
and i guess my guess is that in four
years of of the
harris biden administration that you're
going to actually see
uh enormous influx probably in the
neighborhood of
six to 15 million people speaking of uh
costly
yesterday the house passed the 1.9
trillion dollar covid relief bill
uh it sounds like joe biden's going to
be signing it tomorrow
there will be a big uh you know a big
celebration
and things like that but you know what
happened to the unity
we heard joe biden talk about you know i
want everybody to be together and we're
going to go forward we're not going to
do all that party line stuff
so far everything they've done mr
speaker is party line
and it's not like joe biden's running
the party it's nancy and chuck are
telling joe what to do
well and i think kamala harris i think i
really do think this is becoming
the harris biden administration and you
can sell that every time you see him in
public
i mean why would you think that he's
dramatically better in private
than he is when he can't take any
questions in public he can't remember
what he's talking about
he can't remember his own nominees
my assumption is that he's a very minor
force inside that building
and that the white house is increasingly
run uh by harris pelosi and schumer
and of course they're look these are
hardline liberals these are people who
think that it's fine
that uh walmart or rather that a major
uh drugstore company is closing
every single drugstore in san francisco
because they will no longer prosecute
petty theft
and people have learned you steal up to
950
uh and come back a couple hours later
steal another 950
so you're literally watching the
collapse of what you and i thought of as
civilization
that's the world of pelosi and schumer
and harris
and uh they're happy to give it to the
rest of us
so there is a headline this morning
about a new york city school
it's downtown it's in noho which is
nolita in soho area
and it's called grace church school
parents pay
57 000 a year to send their kids here
it's a very popular school
and they sent out they sent out a
12-page memo
to all the students and to the parents
saying you don't need to say certain
words
at home including mom and dad
they now want you to say grown-up folks
family or guardian they say don't ask
anyone where you're from you need to say
what is your cultural
or ethnic background they don't want you
to say merry christmas they want you to
say
happy holidays or have a great break
instead of boys and girls guys ladies
and gentlemen
you need to say people folks friends
readers
or mathematicians what's your reaction
well look the nobody's noticed it yet
but the house democrats unanimously
voted in their first in the rules
to eliminate mother father brother
sister they took they took out
29 gender specific names
when you look at these things you have
to realize you're dealing for example
with a bill which is essentially the gay
and transsexual
supremacy act which basically says you
can practice your religion as long as
you don't offend anybody
uh but you're it'll be illegal if you
offend anybody
and i think we're seeing a tremendous
assault
on the whole the whole notion of whether
there are males and females
you had the president signed an
executive order that allows
transsexual males to compete as though
they're females which we know
guarantees the end of women's sports
because if you grow up through your
teenage years
males simply are going to win most of
the contests
we are in a period where the weirdest
people
this will get me in trouble for saying
it but i think i'm old enough that i
grew up in a different world
i grew up in a world where we recognize
that there really were mother and father
and we thought it was a good idea to
have a mother and a father
we thought it was a good idea to
recognize boys and girls
you know in california there's a bill in
the legislature that would make it
illegal
for a department store to have a boys
section on a girls section
uh this this is a madness i recently did
a podcast
uh with with sad god and
he's amazing because he says basically
we now have parasites in our brain
that are that are they're cultural
parasites
and the people are just literally crazy
and i think you're seeing examples of
the craziness
and let's move on uh we can go on this
forever but sadly it's coming from
america
and it's infecting the world it's
usually the opposite and i'm embarrassed
by it
meanwhile i'm not embarrassed about this
a four-part look
uh on fox nation about rush limbaugh
where he came from the impact he made
and while he'll continue to resonate in
the future you saw it up close and
personal your eyes mimicked his rise
here you are commenting on the rush
limbaugh you knew
let me track my knowledge
my becoming aware of newt gingrich for
you it's the early 80s and the democrats
and the media are just creaming reagan
every day personally his ideas
his policies and i'd go home
when i had a night friend i'd want
c-span
and there was this guy doing special
orders
he and a couple of his associates were
speaking to an empty house chamber but
as long as somebody was in there
speaking
c-span had to cover it this guy was
ronald reagan jr and it was newt
gingrich i had it backwards nude
what did it feel did you know that rush
was out there and that he was
supporting you well
look rush uh went national in 1988
uh he was a strong ally of ours uh he
was a big factor in our victory in 1994
with the
contract with america he and reagan
had an ability to use common language
so the average person could understand
it to describe things that were so
blatantly true
that they just they both just sort of
ran over their opponents
with the sheer logic of their language
and russia was a major force
i say prior to the rise of fox news he
was probably the most important
populist conservative force in the
country and we are a different country
to better country
because of rush limbaugh you know he was
such a good
explainer he was a great entertainer and
a broadcaster
but he would go into what other
broadcasters would never in a million
years talk about
on the radio and he'd talk about it for
an hour and by the end it's like
oh that makes perfect sense well i i got
a question for you
who who takes over for him
because he is leaving a gigantic void in
the world of broadcasting
well i mean i think mark stein probably
has the the inside track as a
really interesting intellectual who's
also
very funny and very capable doing it
he's been doing russia's show for a good
bit
uh and and uh as russia was taking
chemotherapy and uh i certainly think
he's a possibility
nobody's gonna replace rush i mean
russia was a unique person
uh probably the person who's come
closest to replacing him is sean hannity
if you look at
henry does three hours of radio a day
and then an hour of television at night
he has a huge audience but even sean
would say
that rush had a unique set of abilities
you were exactly right he understood he
had to entertain you
yeah to get you to stay listening long
enough that he could educate you
and as a result uh he had a huge
audience
and and he was genuinely funny i mean
they're not many people
that have as good a sense of humor as uh
as rush did reagan was another one
but rush was probably funnier than
reagan and worked at being funny
understood
his real power was you liked
listening to him not just you learned
but you liked
you had a personal relationship and he
had a personal relationship with about
23 million people
it's a remarkable achievement
yeah they were all so sad it was a sad
day when he passed away many of them had
listened to him for 32 years
thank you so much newt